Pararse ahí con el sombrero se sentía muy similar a rogar.
Y reconocí su temor de "¿Es esto justo?" y "Consigue un trabajo".
Y mientras tanto, mi banda es cada vez más grande.
Firmamos con un sello importante.
Y nuestra música es una mezcla entre punk y cabaret.
No es para todo el mundo.
Bueno, tal vez es para ustedes.
Firmamos y hay toda esta algarabía que precede a nuestro siguiente disco.
Sale y vende unas 25 000 copias en las primeras semanas,
y el sello lo considera un fracaso.
Y les dije, "25 000, ¿no es eso mucho?"
Y ellos dijeron, "No, las ventas están bajando. Es un fracaso".
Y se marcharon.
En ese mismo momento, estoy firmando autógrafos y dando abrazos después de un concierto,
y un chico llega
y me da un billete de 10 dólares,
y dice:
"Lo siento, quemé tu CD de un amigo".
(Risas)
"Pero leí tu blog, sé que odias tu sello.
Solo quiero que aceptes este dinero".
Y esto empieza a suceder todo el tiempo.
Me convierto en el sombrero después de mis propios conciertos,
pero tengo que estar ahí parada físicamente y tomar la ayuda de la gente,
y a diferencia del chico de la banda telonera,
realmente tengo mucha práctica estando ahí de pie.
Gracias.
Y en ese momento decidí
Voy a dar mi música gratis
en línea siempre que sea posible,
así que es como Metallica aquí, Napster, malo;
Amanda Palmer aquí, y yo voy a alentar
torrenting, descargas, compartan, pero voy a pedir ayuda,
porque veía que funcionaba en la calle.
Así que salí de mi sello y para mi próximo proyecto
con mi nueva banda, la Gran Orquesta del Robo,
recurrí al 'crowdfunding',
y caí sobre esas miles de conexiones que había hecho,
y pedí a mi público que me arropara.
Y la meta era de 100 000 dólares.
Mis fans me apoyaron con casi 1.2 millones,
que es el mayor proyecto de 'crowdfunding' de música a la fecha.
(Aplausos)
Y se puede ver cuánta gente es.
Son cerca de 25 000 personas.
Y los medios preguntaron, "Amanda,
el negocio de la música está cayendo y tú fomentas la piratería.
¿Cómo hiciste que todas esas personas pagaran por la música?"
Y la verdadera respuesta es, "No hice que pagaran, se los pedí".
Por el mismo acto de pedir a la gente,
me había conectado con ellos,
y cuando te conectas con ellos, la gente quiere ayudarte.
Es algo contrario a la intuición para muchos artistas.
No quieren pedir cosas.
Pero no es fácil. No es fácil pedir.
Y muchos artistas tienen un problema con esto.
Pedir te hace vulnerable.
Y tengo muchas críticas en línea
después de que mi Kickstarter se hizo grande
por continuar con mis locas prácticas de 'crowdsourcing',
específicamente por pedir a los músicos
que son aficionados si querían unirse a nosotros en el escenario
para algunas canciones a cambio de amor y entradas
y cerveza, y esto fue una imagen trucada
que me llegó de un sitio de Internet.
Esto duele de una manera muy familiar.
Hay gente diciendo, "No tienes permiso de
pedir este tipo de ayuda",
me recuerda realmente de la gente en sus coches gritando, "Consige un trabajo".
Porque no estaban con nosotros en la acera,
y no podían ver el intercambio
que sucedía entre yo y mi gente,
un intercambio que fue muy justo para nosotros pero ajeno a ellos.
Así que esto es algo ligeramente inseguro para el trabajo.
Esta es mi fiesta de soporte de Kickstarter en Berlín.
Al final de la noche, me desnudé y dejé que todos dibujaran sobre mí.
Ahora, déjenme decirles que, si quieren experimentar
la sensación visceral de confiar en extraños,
les recomiendo esto,
especialmente si los extranjeros son alemanes borrachos.
Se trataba de una conexión de fans de ninja a nivel maestro,
porque lo que realmente estaba diciendo aquí era,
confío tanto así en Uds.,
¿debería? Muéstrenme.
Durante la mayor parte de la historia humana,
los músicos, los artistas han sido parte de la comunidad,
conectores y abridores, no estrellas intocables.
Ser una celebridad es acerca de un montón de gente que te ama a la distancia,
pero el contenido y el Internet
que podemos compartir libremente en él
nos llevan al pasado.
Se trata de unas pocas personas que te aman de cerca
y con esas personas es suficiente.
Así que muchas personas se confunden con la idea
de no tener un precio concreto en la etiqueta.
Lo ven como un riesgo imprevisible, pero las cosas que he hecho,
el Kickstarter, la calle, el timbre,
yo no veo estas cosas como riesgos.
Los veo como confianza.
Ahora, las herramientas en línea para hacer el intercambio
tan fácil y tan instintivo como en la calle,
están llegando aquí.
Pero las herramientas perfectas no van a servirnos
si no podemos mirarnos unos a otros
y dar y recibir sin miedo,
pero, más importante,
pedir sin vergüenza.
He pasado mi carrera musical
tratando de encontrar personas en Internet
de la forma que lo hice en esta caja,
así que bloguear y tuitear no solo sobre las fechas de mi giras
y mi nuevo video, sino sobre nuestro trabajo y nuestro arte
y nuestros temores y nuestras resacas, nuestros errores
y nos vemos unos a otros.
Creo que cuando realmente nos vemos mutuamente,
queremos ayudarnos unos a otros.
Creo que la gente se ha obsesionado con la pregunta equivocada:
"¿Cómo hacemos para que la gente pague por la música?"
Qué pasaría si empezamos a preguntar:
"¿Cómo dejamos que la gente pague por la música?"
Gracias.
(Aplausos)